قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي انه اكد لرئيس
هيئه الاركان الامريكيه جنرال مارك ميلي
الذي يزور اسرائيل حاليا اهميه استمرار
العمل لمنع ايران من امتلاك اسلحه نوويه
ويبحث تل ابيب بحسب واشنطن التحديه في
اسرائيل والمنطقه اثناء زيارته التي تعقب
مناورات امريكيه اسرائيليه حاكت تنفيذه
ضربه جويه لمنشات ايران النوويه بحسب تل
ابيب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي ابعاد المحادثات
التي يجريها رئيس الاركان الامريكي في تل
ابيب وما حجم التقاطع بين الاولويات
الامريكيه والاسرائيليه فيما يخص مقومات
الاستقرار في المنطقه ثم نبحث في حدود
التاثير الذي يمكن ان تتركه المشاورات
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه الراهنه على مساء
استئناف المحادثات الخاصه بالملف النووي
الايراني بالنظر الى الاجنده الاسرائيليه
في هذا الصدد ثم وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان
ينعكس التصعيد الاسرائيلي في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله على صياغه اهداف
واولويات امريكيه اسرائيليه مشتركه سيما
بعد تاكيد واشنطن قلقها من بعض مواقف اقصى
اليمين في حكومه نتنياهو
[موسيقى]
اثناء زياره اتفقت واشنطن وتل ابيب على ان
شاغلها الابرز هو مناقشه التحديات التي
تواجه اسرائيل والمنطقه التقى رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكي مارك ميلي في تل ابيب
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي الذي قال انه اكد
لملي اهميه استمرار العمل لمنع ايران من
امتلاك اسلحه نوويه ويشمل جدول زياره
الاديب بحسب وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه
لقاءات مع نظيره الاسرائيلي ومسؤولين
امليين اخرين بينهم رئيس جهاز المصاد كما
ان الزياره تاتي بحسب وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه في ظل توتر بين الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والاداره الامريكيه خلال
الاسابيع الاخيره
هذا وتتزامن زياره رئيس الاركان الامريكيه
تل ابيب مع اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي انهاء
مناورات بريه مشتركه مع قوات من البحريه
الامريكيه شملت تنسيق ضربه جويه مشتركه
للمنشات النوويه الايرانيه بمشاركه عشرات
الطائرات المقاتله والاسطول البحري الذي
دم سفنا حربيه وغواصات وحامله طائرات
امريكيه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور خليل العناني كبير الباحثين
بالمركز العربي في واشنطن ومن غزه الدكتور
صالح النعامي الخبير في شؤون الاسرائيليه
اهلا بكم ابدا معك من وظائف من واشنطن
خليل العناني عندما نتكلم عن زيارات لهذا
المستوى في انتظار الزياره المرتقبه لوزير
الدفاع الامريكي عن اي محادثات نتكلم عن
اي تنسيق بين الطرفين في ظل العلاقه
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه هذه الايام
الكريم ولكل المشاهدين انا اعتقد نحن
ايذاء محاوله امريكيه لخفض تصعيد المتزايد
في الضفه الغربيه خاصه بعدما حدث الاسبوع
الماضي في بلده حواره في جنوب نابلس ان
هناك شعور امريكي بان هذه الحكومه اليمنيه
المطرفه تسعى بشكل او باخر الى افشال كل
محاولات امريكا لتهدئه الاوضاع هي تعمل
بشكل حفيظ جدا على انهاء كل ما يتعلق بحمض
الفلسطينيه كما نرى تقوم ببناء مستوطنات
جديده تضرب بعرض الحائط كل المحاولات
الامريكيه للتهدئه تحاول قتل ورد حلم دوله
فلسطينيه كمان عالم جميعنا وبالتالي هناك
محاوله امريكيه لمنع انزلاق العلاقات
الفلسطينيه الى منحدر جديد هناك الشعور
امريكي بان هناك امكانيه الاندلاع حرب
جديده خاصه مع دخول شهر رمضان المعظم مع
دخول الاعياد اليهوديه وبالتالي هناك
محاوله امريكيه استباقيه تهدئه الاوضاع
وارسال رسائل كبيره جدا لحكومه تتنياهو
بان هذا الامر غير مقبول شكل ابو اخر
راينا على مدار اخر
عندما يتكلم الطرفان عن الاستقرار في
المنطقه والحسابات في المنطقه وكذلك في
اسرائيل هذه الدعوه الى التهدئه الداخليا
وارتباطها بملفات خارجيه تحديدا عندما
نتكلم عن الملف النووي الايراني
والمناورات التي تمت ماذا عن الحسابات
الاسرائيليه في هذا الشان
يعني بدايه هذه
هذا اللقاء الذي تم بين
رئيس الاركان الامريكي ووزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي ياتي في بعد اعلان نائم وزير
الدفاع الامريكي امام مجلس النواب
الامريكي الثلاثه الماضي لانه ايران في
غضون 12 يوم بامكانها ان تحصل على المواد
اليورانيوم المخصه بالكافي لانتاج قنبله
نوويه واحده ثم بعد ان اعلنت
الوكاله الدوليه الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
بانه ايران انه انها ضبطت وحصل على عينات
تؤكد بان ايران قامت برفع نسبه التخصيب
الى 83%
83.4
من التقسيم طبعا هذه الزياره يجب علينا ان
ننظر الى مجمل التحركات ما بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واسرائيل الاحد بعد غدا
الاحد سيتوجه
رئيس المجلس الامن القومي الاسرائيلي صح
يا نجبي ووزير الشؤون الاستراتيجيه
رونديرمر الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
للتركيز على هذا الجانب تحديدا على موضوع
التطورات على صعيد
البرنامج النووي الايراني بالنسبه بالنسبه
الاتفاق والاختلاف بين اسرائيل بالنسبه
للمقال الدكتور خليل هو بالفعل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تتخوف مما تقوم بهذه
الحكومه ولكنها في نفس الوقت لا تغفل
القواسم المشتركه مع الاسرائيل فيما يتعلق
بالبرنامج انه هو الايراني وان كان هذا
الموضوع ايضا في هناك ثمه صحيح ان
الولايات المتحده واسرائيلي اتفقان على
على عدم السماح لايران بانتاج سلاح نووي
ولكن هناك ايضا حتى في هذه النقطه في
اختلاف لانه اسرائيل ترفض ان تصل اسرائيل
الول ايه ايران الى الى مكانه
قدرات نوويه يعني دكتور صالح حتى على
الجانب الاسرائيلي وتصريح لرئيس هيئه
الاركان الاسرائيليه يقول بان العمليات
الاخيره في غزه تكلفنا او العمليه الامنيه
في غزه تكلفنا ثمنا باردا وهذا ما يدفعنا
للتساؤل هذا الثمن الى اي مدى يؤثر على
الحسابات الامنيه للجانب الاسرائيلي في
الضفه الغربيه
اذا تكلمنا اذا اذا اذا
ركزنا على موضوع الظرف الغربي هناك ثمه
انقسام داخلي في داخل اسرائيل داخل
المؤسسه الامنيه المؤسسه الامنيه بالامس
كما كشفت قناه التلفزه الاسرائيليه
الرسميه كان يعني هناك توصيه من هذه
المؤسسه
يعني تقديم بوادر بين هللين بوادر حسنيه
تجاه السلطه الفلسطينيه المؤسسه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه ترى بانه انه انه بنيامين
نتنياهو فقد السيطره على على قوه اليمين
الديني المتطرف داخل هذه الحكومه وانا
تدفع اسرائيل الى الى مربعات يعني بالغه
الخطوره يعني هذه هذه الاحزاب بالذات
حركتي
صهيونيه الدينيه بقياده وزير الماليه
الذي دعا علانيه الى محو بلده حواره ووزير
الامن القومي الذي يراس حركه عثمان
يهوديتها هاتين الحاتين الحركتان تدفعان
الى الى حسم الصراع مع الشعب الفلسطيني
بكل مكان الكلمه سواء عن طريق السيطره
الارض سواء عن طريق الاستيطان وهذا اولا
يضعف الشرعيه الداخليه داخل اسرائيل
للقيام بجهود حربي سواء على الصعيد
الداخلي وحتى على الصعيد الخارجي مواجهه
ايران او داخليا كما قلت عن مواجهه قطاع
غزه دكتور خليل نقل عن اللقاءات من
الطرفين الامريكي والاسرائيلي بان الجانب
الامريكي نقل للجانب الاسرائيلي ضروره
التهدئه الداخليا عندما يتعلق الامر
بحسابات على مستوى المنطقه او بحسابات ما
يتعلق بالملف النووي الايراني وهذا ما
يدفعنا الى اي مدى تتقاطع
نظره الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بمقومات الامن
في المنطقه والتحكم في الملفات المنطقه
وبين الحسابات الاسرائيليه
انا اعتقد لابد ان نفرق هنا بين اولويات
كل طرف اذا تحدثنا عن طرف الاسرائيلي اهم
ثلاث اولويات له سيتم مرحله تحديدا اولا
انهاء وقتل كما قلت قبل قليل اي حلم خلال
تغيير الاوضاع الديموغرافيه على الارض من
خلال بناء السلطان الجديده من خلال طرد
فلسطيني من قراهم من بيوتهم ونحن نشهد
حاليا محاولات للقيام بنكبه ثانيه بعد 48
وهناك شعور دولي وفلسطين متزايده ان هذه
المحاولات مستمره هناك غطاء اسرائيل حكومه
الها فدي اول حاجه التانيه اولويه هي منع
او بمعنى اخر ضربي ايران عسكريا ليس فقط
مجرد منعها من خلال التفاوض من خلال ضربه
عسكريه وراينا عبد القادر قبل قليل عندما
قلت بان هناك مناورات هي اكبر من نوعيها
بين الجيش الاسرائيلي في المنطقه وهناك
محاكاه لامكانيه توقيت ضربات عسكريه
لايران ثدي اولويه لاسرائيل لو كنت تطبيع
مع الدول العربيه او بالاحرى التحالف
الاستراتي مع الدول العربيه وراينا خلال
اسبوع الماضي الذي سبقه تصريحات عمانيه
بالسماح للطير الاسرائيلي بالطيران فوق
الاوجه الايرانيه رقم عدم وجود اتفاق رسم
للتطبيع بين عمان وبين ايران وبين عفوا
اسرائيل فيما تعلم جانب الامريكي هناك
اولويات تتقاطع وتختلف على سبيل المثال
كما قلت قبل قليل مرحله هي منع التصعيد
منع انزلاق الصراع الا حرب قد تكون حرب
دمويه كما حدث قبل ذلك بعد بعد مشكله حي
الشيخ جراح الامر الثاني متعلق بمنع ايران
وليس بالضرر من خلال اربع عسكريه وراينا
تصريحات بالامس
الامريكيين حول امكانيه تجود وجود تفاوض
مع ايران هناك كما خوفيه كما قلت الصالح
قبل قليل من خلال تصريحات مسؤوليه
المسؤولين كبار بان اصبحت على العتبه
النوويه بمعنى اخر هناك فقط من اجل انتاج
وقود قد يؤدي الى الى تصنيع القنبله نوويه
الامر الثالث طبعا هنا التشارك مع اسرائيل
هو دعم التطبيع وهناك مطالبات في الكونجرس
بتعيين سفير خاص بتفقات ابراه من اجل دعم
التطبيع الدول العربيه مختلفه في بعض
الملفات ولكنها ايضا متشابه في ملفات
الاخرى طيب دكتور صالح ايضا فيما يتعلق
هذه المره بالملف النووي الايراني حتى في
الحكومات السابقه الحسابات الامريكيه
بالابقاع على العوده للتفاوض فيما يتعلق
بهذا الملف كانت تختلف تماما مع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه السابقه كيف الحال الان ومع
حكومه نتنياهو الموصوفه بانها الاكثر
تطرفا والاكثر تشددا وبالتالي ايضا ماذا
عن الحسابات الاسرائيليه هذه المره مع
الحسابات
هي الاكبر بين طرفين
اولا علينا ان
ننظر الى هذه المناورات كرساله ردع للجانب
الايراني سيما في ظل الحديث كما قلت
المسؤول وزير الدفاع الامريكي بانه ايران
على بعد 12 يوم من انتاج الماده المشعه
الكافيه للانتاج قنبله نوويه لكن هناك
ولكن
نعم طبعا ليست الاولى ليست الاولى طبعا
كان في هناك
مناورات في البحر الاحمر بمشاركه الدول
العربيه بالمناسبه بالامارات والبحرين
وهذه كانت بسبب
بدافع التامين تامين الملاحه البحريه سيم
في ظل الحديث عنه انه امكانيه ان تقوم
ايران باستهداف سفن اسرائيليه وقد حدث هذا
الامر ثم ان هناك بشكل واضح هناك لجنه
اسرائيليه امريكيه مشتركه تعنى بمواجهه
غير البرنامج النووي القدرات العسكريه
الايرانيه التقليديه وتحديدا الترسان
الصاروخيه والمصيرات الهجوميه سيما وغزاد
هذا التنسيق ما بين الطرفين بعد ان قامت
ايران بتزويد روسيا بالمسيرات التي
استخدمت على نطاق واسع في الهجوم على على
المدن الاوكرانيه ولكن فيما يتعلق ببرنامج
هناك خلاف جذري كما قلت اسرائيل تعتبر انه
يتوجب العمل العسكريا ضد المنشاه ضد يعني
بعمل كبير من بنى اسرائيل من التحول الى
دوله ذات قدرات نوويه يعني دوله بامكان ان
تحصل على المواد المشعه ضوء حتى لو لم يتم
تحويل هذه المواد المشعه الى الى سلاح
ولكن بينما بينما الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كما عبر عن ذلك الرئيس بايدن
وكبار الموظفي الاداره بانها
ستعمل عسكريا ضد ايران في حال انتجت
السلاح النووي وهذا الفرق ما بين الطرفين
وبالمناسبه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تتبنى هذه الايام وقفت اكثر اعتدالا حتى
من الدول الاوروبيه يعني الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حتى بعد تقرير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه النوويه الطاقه الذريه بانه ضبطت
عينات تفيد منه ايران خاصه 83.4 من عشره
حتى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه غير معنيه
باتخاذ قرار ضد ايران في الوكاله وهذا
لفتح المجال للقاء على امكانيه العوده
للاتفاق النووي
للتساؤل عن
مصير امكانيه هذه العوده لهذا الاتفاق في
ظل ايضا حسابات الاداره او الاداره
الامريكيه من جهه وحسابات الطرف
الاسرائيلي مثلا زياره رئيس الاركان
الامريكيه الى اسرائيل تمهد ايضا بحسب
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه الى زياره وزير
دفاعه كما ذكرت قبل قليل المرتقبه يوم
الاربعاء المقبل الى تل ابيب ضمن جوله
ستاخذ ايضا الى القاهره وعمان هو حراك
يشمل ايضا زياره مرتقبه لوزير الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيلي ورئيس مجلس الامن
القومي الى الولايات المتحده الاسبوع
المقبل حيث سيلتقيان مسؤولين في الاداره
الامريكيه بينهم مستشار الامن جيكس ووزير
الخارجي
وتتركز المحادثات على ايران ايضا حسب ما
ذكر صحيفه معارف الاسرائيلي هنا اعود
لاسال ضيفي من ورشه الدكتور خليل العناني
ايضا في ظل الحسابات الامريكيه فيما يتعلق
بالطاع ات مع الملف النووي الايراني
والحسابات الاسرائيليه في ظل الحكومه بهذا
الشكل ماذا عن الجانب الامر الامريكي في
ظل امر معقد كهذا
عبد القادر انه الذي دفع ايران تصل هذا
المستوى من التخصيب وهو يعني 82% بمعنى
اخر يعني فقط مجرد يعني
وقود نووي هو انسحاب امريكا الانفرادي تحت
اداره ترامب في مايو 2018
بكل اضافي الذي الحق به وبالتالي الموقف
الامريكي بشكل عام يقوم على عده ام الامر
الاول هو اتفاق سيء خير من الله اتفاق
بمعنى اخر هناك قناعه امريكيه بشكل او
باخر نتواصل الاتفاق مع ايران قد يعطل او
يؤجل او يمنع التوجه ايران الى انتاج وقود
قد يؤدي الانتاج قم بها المئويه الامر
الثاني متعلق بان هناك مقاس امريكيه كبيره
جدا من اي اندلاع اي عمل عسكري اسرائيل
وبالتالي يؤدي الى التاثير على صحه
الامريكيه يعني
على الاقل 70 الف جندي في منطقه الخليج
العربي لديك قواعد عسكريه موجوده في
الامارات وفي قطر وفي الكويت وفي العراق
وفي سوريا وبالتالي هناك انتشار امريكي
عسكري قد
هذه الحرب الامر متعلق
بانشغال امريكي واضح جدا سواء بالحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا وبالتالي هناك دعم
امريكي غير مسبوق لهذه الحرب او حتى
بالصراع والتنافس مع الصين وبالتالي هناك
تحول امريكا بشكل اخر باتجاه تلك المنطقه
الملتهب من العالم خاصه يتعلق بمنطقه اسيا
وبالتالي هناك حرص امريكي بقاله تنزلق
الامور باتجاه وجود حرب او عمل عسكري قد
يؤدي الى دفع فواتير مكلفه جدا لامريكا
سواء داخليا هل افهم من كلامك دكتور خليل
ان هناك هواجس حقيقيه لدى الجانب الامريكي
بان الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه قد تلجا
الى عمل منفرد نتائجه تكون بالدرجه الاولى
على الوجود الامريكي في المنطقه وعلى
المصالح الامريكيه في المنطقه
بلا شك هناك تخوف امريكي من عدم وجود اي
نوع من اي لكام يلزم هذه الحكومه هذه
الحكومه حكومه كما قلنا قبل قليل اكثر
ومطرفه في عهد اسرائيل الحكومه اليمنيه
فاشيه تبتسم بالعنصريه وبالتالي قد تلجه
الى اي عمل متهول فيما يتعلق بالعلاقه
بشكل عام من الصعب جدا تخيل وجود اي ضربه
اسرائيليه الايران بدون موافقه امريكيه
على الاقل سماح امريكي الامر متوقف على
كيف تكون اسرائيل باخراج هذه المساله
بالفعل هناك بالفعل حاليا حرب خفيه على
مدار اخر سنتين هناك استهداف اسرائيل واضح
جدا العلماء سواء علماء في الذره او في في
الطاقه النوويه الايرانيين او استهداف
العلماء في الصواريخ الباليستيه او حتى
استهداف لعلماء في مجالات اخرى وبالتالي
هناك بالفعل استهداف اسرائيل لهذه لهذه
المساله لكن هناك ايضا حرص اسرائيلي على
عدم خسران امريكا في النهايه تمثل حليف
استراتيجي مهم جدا لاسرائيل سواء حاليا في
عسكري حاليا في اقتصادي حليف دبلوماسي
يعطيها غطاء دبلوماسي دوله وبالتالي من
الصعب جدا ان تقوم بعمل بشكل منفرد قد
يكون هناك محاوله لايهام امريكا كم حدثت
في حرب العراق 2003 بان هناك بالفعل انتاج
لسلاح نووي ايران وبالتالي تدعم الموقف
بتاعها من هذه المساله وسوف تقوم بجر
امريكا بشكل اخر الى هذه الحرب اتوقع انه
من الصعب ان نشهد حرب خلال العميل
المقبلين اداره ضعيفه ممتازه انها ايضا
مساله ربما لو جاءت اداره
جمهوريه في المرحله القادمه كما كان الحال
مع عهد ترامب ترامب كان يعطي بالامس في
تسريبات لانتريسبت موقع انتر ستيب يتحدث
عن وجود خطه امريكيه لشن ضربات عسكريه
اتجاه ايران لو هناك سلاحنا هناك استعداد
جمهوري على الاقل تقبل فكره القيام بشان
ضربات عسكريه على موقع نوال الايراني نحن
امام تقاطع اكثر من ملف سواء داخلي فيما
يتعلق بالصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي وايضا
ملفات اخرى في المنطقه ملفات امريكيه
اسرائيليه وكل هذا تحت عباءه الملف النووي
الايراني وهنا اسال ضيفي من غزه الدكتور
صالح
يبدو ان هذه الحكومه ماضيه في قراراتها
التقت في العقبه ثم انقلبت على هذا
الاتفاق حتى مثلا هذا اليوم وفد اوروبي
زار بعض البلدات وبعدها بقليل عاد
المستوطنون وهجموا على هذه البلدات
وبالتالي عندما يتعلق الامر بحكومه بهذه
المواصفات ماذا عسل الجانب الامريكي ان
يفعل حتى وان كان هناك انزال دبلوماسي على
مستوى وزاره وزير الدفاع في الايام
القادمه وتحرك لمسؤولين من الطرفين تجاه
العاصمتين
يعني اول علينا نتذكر استاذ عبد القادر
[موسيقى]
الدكتور خليل فيما يتعلق بحساسيه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اتجاه ما تقوم به
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لانه هذه الاداره
الامريكيه التي تحركت لانقاذ اسرائيل
وضغطت على النظامين في مصر والاردن للنساء
المديرين المخابرات لرام الله والضغط على
السلطه لحضور التراجع لحضور مؤتمر العقبه
والتراجع عن تقديم قرار في مجلس الامن
يعني يدين اسرائيل
يعني شاهدنا ما حدث في العقبه وفي نفس
الليله حدث ما حدث من فضائع في في حواره
لذلك الاداره الامريكيه للاسف الشديد يعني
هي
تدرك بانه ما تقوم بهذه الحكومه قد يؤثر
سلبا ويؤثر سلبا على الاستقرار ولكن هذه
الاداره لا يمكن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بشكل عام غير قادر على اتخاذ
خطوات عمليه
لاقناع هذه الحكومه بالتوقف عن جنون
التطارب علينا الذكر اسرائيل اليوم يعني
الرغم من كل هذا التهديدات في لم تكن اضعف
مما هي عليه الان هناك يعني
عرائد من من
[موسيقى]
تحت معظم الاذرع العسكريه في اسرائيل في
سلاح الطيران المخابرات الاستخبارات كلهم
يعلنون بانهم يتوقفون عن الخدمه العسكريه
والتطوع في الخدمه العسكريه بسبب
الاصلاحات القضائيه التي يشرع بنيامين او
شرعا في تمريرها لانقاذه من المحاكمه لذلك
يعني يعني الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
للاسف تقوم بدور سلبي في هذا الجانب شكرا
فقط معنيه يعني بدفع ضريبه كلاميه ولكنها
لا شكرا لك للاسف ادركنا الوقت من غزه
دكتور صالح
وكذلك الشكر لضيفي من واشنطن الدكتور خليل
العناني
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه بالبرنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]